the problem with being a hero is you
have to be willing to die for what you
believe in hey titanfall 2 it's a thing
and a teaser trailer today was short but
included some key plot details here's
what you might have missed the crash
lifeboat has the name James Macallan on
the front mcallen was a lead character
in titanfall one first seen at this set
of gravestones on the colony map and
last seen sacrificing his life to
overload a reactor and crippled the IMC
fleet he's a turncoat who led a mutiny
15 years before titanfall one and was
the executive officer on an imc ship
called the Odyssey that ship was sent by
the IMC on a peacekeeping mission into
the frontier but started oppressing
civilians instead of protecting them
that means that this shot is likely a
flashback or possibly hints that
titanfall 2 is a prequel since the only
time an escape pod would have McAllen's
name on it is one who was the XO of the
Odyssey the Titan that steps in the
frame has the same toes and backward
bending knee joint as a Strider which is
a light Recon variant and makes sense if
somebody was coming to investigate a
crash only this Strider seems to have a
little bit more armor so it might be a
new class of Titan in between a Strider
and an atlas it has an unfamiliar logo
on the left leg all of which points to
this being the moment of contact when
Macallan met a ragtag group of rebelling
frontier citizens and organize them into
the militia of titanfall one
the next thing you should take note of
is the sword not only is there a sword
probably in game in titanfall too but
there's two pieces of information on the
blade we can only speculate about the
meaning though first up are the words
EHR titanium series there are a number
of manufacturers in the titanfall
universe including the most infamous ham
and robotics so this might be a new
player on the scene next is a serial
number reddit is hard at work on this
one but it appears to contain the words
ps4 xbox one and pc on it other
speculation is that the m.o.b letters at
the beginning might indicate a
multiplayer open beta date again this is
all early speculation we'll find out a
lot more on june twelfth at the e3
reveal so what are your theories on the
Titans all 2 teaser trailer feel free to
tell us in the comments below and for
more coverage of titanfall to stay tuned
to gamespot com
you
you